as we define our goals and key
performance indicators
or kpis for whatever business or
personal case
we need to make sure we're actually
creating objectives that matter
goals objectives and kpis are tools
they have a use they need to be designed
and used with intention
and a best practice of defining goals
and kpis is using the smart criteria
in this video we'll define the smart
criteria with relatable examples
and provide some best practice
guidelines for making your own smart
goals
smart goals are ones that set objectives
and kpis in a precise and easy to
communicate way
first described in print 1981 by author
george doran and later expanded by
professor robert rubin
smart is an acronym that stands for
specific
measurable achievable
realistic and time-bound
smart states that clear attainable
strategic goals
are the most effective way to create
concrete milestones and metrics
instead of a general goal like increase
sales we might consider a smart goal
like
increase february's year-over-year
premium subscription sales in california
by four percent
smart goals are the individual steps of
a well-considered strategy to achieving
larger
objectives if you were running a
marathon or climbing a mountain
smart goals would be the mile markers
along the way letting you know where you
are and how well you're doing
it isn't just about getting to the end
but rather what steps to take to get
there
smart kpis are what smart goals use as
the accountable measurements with a
start and end
specific being clear about your goals
and expectations
is the first step to reaching them when
goals are too wide or vague
they are easy to mississippi if the
definition is too broad
they become harder to measure and also
harder to achieve
being too vague allows for a lot of
error and misunderstanding
it's like climbing a mountain not
knowing how long the path is
how long it's supposed to take what the
conditions are or even what to wear
while doing it
with specific goals you can see a path
formed from start to finish
specific kpis define the path even
further with benchmarks
ensuring everyone knows exactly where
you are
when you create your smart goal try to
answer questions like
what are the concrete steps in our plan
who
is necessary to make it happen where
will our efforts take place
why is this valuable to our long-term
strategy
how do we prioritize this goal compared
to other goals
example of a specific smart goal if
superman is trying to save the world
then he's going to be more specific by
narrowing the objective to prevent lex
luthor's plan
this helps superman be a lot more
focused in his goals
and helps him prioritize stopping a
super villain over saving the endangered
ivory-billed woodpecker from extinction
measurable if you can't measure
something you can't tell if you're
performing well or if you're off track
and need to course correct
in addition to being specific in your
goals you need to be able to quantify
your data or indicate where you are
progressing towards your goal
setting measurable goals and criteria
also lets everyone involved evaluate
their performance and stay on track
when you create your smart goal try to
answer questions like
what data do we need where will our data
live
and how will we access it is our data
reliable and verifiable
what are reasonable milestones how much
is enough and how much is not enough
how will we know we've accomplished our
goal
example of a measurable smart goal if
your goal is to climb a mountain
in a day then you'd likely do some
research and plan out how many miles to
hike per hour and track your progress
you would then measure your distance in
time according to your goal
this is a much smarter plan than instead
looking up to the top of the mountain in
the afternoon
and just starting to walk hoping to the
top by sundown
achievable it's important to look at
your end objectives and plan out goals
that are within realistic capabilities
it's also important not to get too
carried away and use farfetched or
unreachable goals as motivators
constantly chasing an impossibly lofty
goal allow yourself
and your stakeholders to feel motivated
by the satisfaction of achievement and
real progress
when setting goals be ambitious and push
for success
but also understand internal and
external limits achievement needs to be
sustainable
when you create your smart goal try to
answer questions like
what are the necessary steps to achieve
this goal
how much direct control do we have over
achieving this goal
is this goal realistic compared to
previous performance
what is the precedent why do we think
this goal is achievable
what external and internal factors might
prevent us from achieving this goal
example of an achievable smart goal
search and rescue dogs have a singular
purpose to find survivors of disasters
like earthquakes or terrorism attacks
in order to keep the dogs motivated in a
specially fatal disaster areas
dog handlers will sometimes hide fake
survivors for the dogs to rescue so the
dogs will be motivated to continue their
hard work
the gratification of achievement
empowers and sustains the continued good
behavior of achievement
realistic and relevant similar to the
achievable criteria above
goals also need to be realistic and
relevant
setting goals that are completely out of
reach won't make your team strive to
reach harder
but at the same time setting goals that
are too easy won't make your team better
it's also important to make sure your
goals are relevant to your goals or
business objectives over time
kpis need to measure your business goals
over short-term
and long-term strategies and it's okay
to adjust criteria
as time passes what works now won't
always work the same later
and it's important to identify when
business needs change
stay aware of your long-term goals but
don't be afraid to readjust the
short-term tactics that will help
achieve those long-term plans
when you create your smart goal try to
answer questions like
why is this the goal now why wasn't this
the goal in the past
who are the right people to pursue this
goal how will this goal advance a
long-term strategy
what is the anticipated return on
investment roi
what would it mean if we failed to reach
this goal
example of a realistic smart goal
if your ultimate goal is to climb mount
everest but you've never climbed a whole
mountain before
it would be unrealistic to head straight
to everest
the criteria suggested above indicate
that you should first be asking yourself
why you should be trying to hike mount
everest at all
if you're the right person to be hiking
mount everest and what it would mean if
you didn't make it to the top
if you decided to proceed you then would
need to plot out a realistic training
schedule for the feet
time bound the final letter of smart is
often overlooked
but it's incredibly important to have a
time frame for your goals
a time-bound goal can consist of either
start and end points or a collection of
timed parameters or milestones
you may have a deadline to reach certain
objectives in order to stay on track
or you may want to track metrics across
a period of time
whether it's daily monthly or quarterly
whatever you choose plan ahead of time
to make sure your kpis can be measured
as time passes in order for you to reach
your goals in a timely manner
when you create your smart goal try to
answer questions like
is this achievable in the given time
frame
what is the longest and shortest
possible time to achieve this goal
what potential blockers or time related
factors could delay progress
what have we accomplished in similar
time frames in the past
when and how will we check for progress
what do we do if we're off track halfway
through
are there any times where progress might
naturally slow down
or speed up example of a time-bound
smart goal
for a simple health example consider
everyone's favorite new year's
resolution
i'm going to go to the gym more a smart
fitness goal might include defining
exactly how often and for how long will
go to the gym
instead of a very general goal you might
resolve to go to the gym three days a
week for one hour each day for the next
month
or if you wanted to lose weight you
might make a time-bound fitness goal
like this
i'm going to lose 10 pounds over the
next three months
you might then decide and check in
milestones every two weeks to stay on
track
of course it would be up to the rest of
the smart criteria
to determine other details about the how
of this goal
in summary a smart goal is used to help
guide goal setting
smart is an acronym that stands for
specific measurable
achievable realistic and timely
therefore a smart goal incorporates all
of these criteria to help focus your
efforts
and increase the chances of achieving
that goal